Speaker 1: Governor of California, Gavin Newsom,
did an interview on MSNBC with Jen Psaki.
And I want to take a look at two moments from
this.
The first, he just very accurately.
Diagnosis and raises alarm about the moment
that we're in in this country where rights
are being rolled back and people are being
targeted in some terrifying ways.
Take a look at this and then we'll discuss.
Speaker 3: Also don't get what's going on
in this country.
I don't get why everybody is not doing what
we're doing.
I don't understand it.
Do people understand it's not just about Mar-A-Lago.
It's not just about what's happening in Washington,
D.C., or what's happening in New York court
or the district attorney.
There's something deep and serious that's
happening across this country.
All the progress the last half century is
being rolled back in these states in real
time just the last few years.
I don't think people fully understand the
rights regression, individual liberties on
civil rights, on voting rights and the gerrymandering
that's happening out here on just the assault
on the African-American community, the assault
on the gay, lesbian, bisexual and trans community.
The number one issue of the day seems to be
getting rid of the word Latin X in Arkansas.
And number two, getting rid of drag shows.
It's a serious moment in American history.
And yet we're so consumed respectfully by
the spectacles in Washington that I, as an
American, feel compelled as a governor to
call that out and expose some of that in a
more systemic way.
And forgive me for being intense about this,
but everything I have taken for granted in
my life in the last half century in terms
of rights, expansion and even bring up abortion
and contraception, all of that, all of that
is in peril at this moment in my kids.
They need if I care about my kids, I sure
as hell better care about what's going on
in Alabama, what's going on in Mississippi,
in Arkansas.
And you know what?
I'm coming back a much better governor because
I spent a long weekend with my kids here.
Speaker 1: I took a trip to Arkansas.
But it's absolutely right because of the.
Almost reality TV nature wild drama that is
American politics right now.
It can be easy to get distracted from some
of the significant ways in which damaging
actions are being taken by the Republican
Party and by this modern right wing that is
driving the Republican Party.
And I think Gavin Newsom, better than a lot
of those within within the Democratic Party,
is able to call attention to that in a tone
that matches the moment.
I think we see a lot of Democrats who maybe
they realize the moment that we're in and
maybe they try to call it and do it, but it
just doesn't match in it, tone in rhetoric
the way.
That it should.
The moment that we're in, and that's what
Gavin Newsom does very effectively, because
it's scary abortion rights being targeted,
even though clearly America's not on board
with that with the way that we are voting.
As he noted, the LGBTQ community, the refusal
to address problems such as gun violence and
racial inequality and income inequality, and
on and on it goes.
It just is so enraging that that's what we're
dealing with.
But it is.
And we can't let the Mar a Lago debacle.
Those are important, too.
And Trump's legal troubles distract from the
significant things that also have to be focused
on.
Next moment from this interview here.
Speaker 3: It sickens me in my core and I'll
tell you and you would have more insight than
anybody so you can validate what happened
in Tennessee triggered this trip.
Just triggered.
I called the White House.
Full disclosure, I said, I can't take it.
I can't.
I got for you.
I was given speeches.
The same speech you've seen every politician
give.
Monterey Park down in Salinas.
I gave it prior down in Gilroy when I was
mayor.
We see the dance ball.
I mean, I can't.
I just can't take it.
I can't take it.
And then to see the same governors, these
talk about mental health, you know, unique
apparently, in America, to talk about, you
know, our parents and our family.
I mean, all the beat us and then they claim
to care about life when the number one cause
of death for our children is guns.
Shameful.
They're shameful.
And it should shock our souls.
But it's becoming so normalized.
It's amount of hours now, not even days.
I mean, I thought we would never move on from
Parkland or never move on from Uvalde.
They never move on from Buffalo.
I had to read the manifesto.
I read the manifesto from the shooter in Buffalo.
I still have chills thinking about that manifesto
to understand this.
This is serious.
The manifesto allegedly for the shooter in
Tennessee.
All connected this broader contagion.
They don't care about our kids because if
they did, they ban these damn weapons of war.
They would have background checks.
They require some common damn sense.
They don't.
So you know what?
Those kids that were there in the Capitol.
God bless every single one of them.
Speaker 1: We've talked a good bit about this
subject on today's show, but I just don't
know how else to say it.
It's so true what he's saying, that if you're
going to say you're the party of protecting
the kids, as the GOP has been saying.
And then turn around and side with your distorted
this distorted and inaccurate incorrect view
of what the Second Amendment means, that it
means you can't regulate at all.
Firearms.
Over the lives of.
Children and people of all ages, but because
they say they want to protect the kids.
You're not being honest.
You don't.
That's not an authentic motivation for the
things that you're doing.
It feels nice to say.
Whenever it comes time for.
You two demonize LGBTQ people.
But no, it's not an authentic ambition to
protect the kids because you would start if
you cared about that, you would start with
the leading cause of death for children, no
doubt.
And so to choose again, that incorrect interpretation
that has been created of the Second Amendment
over the lives of our children highlights
better than anything else.
More accurately than anything else, the dishonesty
of that whole narrative.
And it's sickening to watch day after day.
We just got news of another mass shooting
in Louisville.
Five people dead.
And.
There are schools, but they're also all over
the place at a bank and there are lives being
lost.
And also the terror that is injected into
just the lives of people when they know this
could happen anywhere at any time.
And all of that is not necessary.
It really is not necessary.
Nothing.
Makes that more clear than the fact that we're
the only country that experiences when we
compare ourselves to other developed countries.
This type of gun violence, these numbers in
terms of mass shootings, and to think that's
just a coincidence and the reason why other
countries don't see this gun violence is just
because they don't have problems with mental
health for some magical reason.
No.
It is clear what needs to be done and is not
being done is being blocked from being done
by so many within the Republican Party.